wow ich aber wieder auf google maps
unterwegs und habe verstörende sachen
gefunden ich würde sagen wir starten
einfach mal hier in buenos aires wir
sind was ist was ist das
was was soll hier einmal nicht darum
geht es allerdings nicht in buenos aires
denn es geht um dafür
foto bommel blatt ja es stimmt video
startet schon wieder super machen
allerdings hier direkt weiter mit einem
ort in texas und genau so stelle ich mit
texas auch vorne
einfach dazu gar nichts es soll
allerdings nicht um gar nichts gehen in
dieser stadt in diesem google maps ort
sondern es geht um diese kirche
beziehungsweise um das hier
das
das ist ein geist
ja wir schon wieder richtig scheiße tut
mir leid
er mache mich allerdings weiter mit
einem ort in brasilien und zwar habe ich
einen kleinen hund der 1
jetzt müsst ihr das video licon weil es
ist ein kleiner süßer hund bleiben wir
allerdings direkt in brasilien meiner
lieben freunde genau so stelle ich mir
übrigens brasilien vor hier sollen drei
tage irgendwie ihr so ein paar berge es
geht aber um das hier sind nämlich
irgendwie 70.000 kühe und dann wenn man
ein bisschen vorfahren des google street
view autos mitten in den kühlen drin
liegen noch ein bisschen weiter vor wir
befinden uns immer noch in den kühen das
überhaupt
ja okay gut was soll ich sonst sagen wir
mal den arsch vom vordermann ablecken
alles klar hier befinden wir uns in
spanien und hier ist alles ziemlich
baustelle allerdings geht es um diese
frau die einfach keinen kann unser
körper hat
läuft nicht so bei dir hier befinden wir
uns in chile und es sieht sehr schön aus
die ganze landschaft der himmel ist
megaschön hier ist einfach eine schöne
straße zum langfahren sich ein bisschen
in die natur verlieben und damit dass
hier eine passende kuh da sage ich mich
nun allerdings von chile komplett rüber
nach holland zwar nach amsterdam eine
wunder wunderschöne stadt die ich liebe
amsterdam über alles was ich allerdings
nicht verstehe ist dass hier
einfach einfach mal ein
fand im sommer so völlig unbeobachtet
dann baden gehen hier im pool
das ist in santa cruz
und
das ist
wirklich entspannt hier vor allem bei
nacht
zu fahren ich glaube die sind ja auch
einfach mehr weitergefahren
oder doch sonst ich sag mal was habt ihr
denn für eier aus stahl dass ihr bei
solchem wetter com ich meine du kannst
immer nur so aller höchstens 20 meter
weit gucken
du kannst fahren und ihr können
plötzlich ein baum auf der straße liegen
oder mörder oder ich oder das neue
patrick frey ich habe das am 20 05 uhr
lukas applaus
gehen wir nun allerdings zurück nach
buenos aires meine lieben freunde und
schauen uns einige polizisten an die die
hunde füttern
er ist das süß guck mal die dogs die
erweisen dem ganzen landen dienst ja
sogar noch den napf in der hand und da
voll werden die gesichter von den
menschen zensiert und nicht die von den
hunden kommen da bin ich ja sogar
hintergrund dieses bild hier stammt
glaube ich irgendwo aus der antarktis
oder irgendwo da und es sind leute die
hier auf dem boot sind allerdings
befindet sich dort
einfach eine riesig hoher turm
ich glaube das ist eigentlich der mast
vom boot aus wie sondern riesig großer
fernsehturm ich glaube allerdings nicht
dass dort jemand unbedingt so was von
der antarktis rüber ins komplette
gegenteil uns vorab nach florida meine
lieben freunde wir sehen schon palmen
wir sind schönes wetter wir sehen schöne
häuser und wir sehen ein auto mit
ja
damit seien
mitgenommen werden kann bei linie und
nun befinden uns allerdings in england
meine lieben freunde ich finde sie sieht
ein bisschen aus wie bei harry potter
hier die die straße beziehungsweise die
häuserreihe allerdings geht es um diese
person
der freut sich nicht pflicht total ist
er auf google maps ist wenn wir ein
bisschen vorgehen sehen wir auch
jetzt halt vorbei zurückgehen
ist ja so richtig so und nun befinden
wir uns hier wieder anders als meine
lieben freunde ist wirklich wundervoll
hier also sehr sehr staub trockenheit
wir haben ein paar wolken am himmel
allerdings geht es nicht um das wetter
in buenos aires sondern es geht hier um
ich weiß nicht was hier passiert ist und
ich will es aber ehrlich gesagt gar
nicht wissen hier befinden wir uns in
kingston ontario ontario ich weiß es
nicht genau wir ihn verlegen wo in
amerika auch wunderschön hier mit der
natur und zweitens ist das hier also ein
kleines zelt 15 kamera darf man hinauf
fahren oder miles ich weiß nicht genau
hier soll die stromleitung und so weiter
und so fort geht allerdings um das hier
und wie süß
einfach mit blumen so und smiley
verklagt ich hab das namensrecht auf ein
smiley ein namensrecht
nicht um die rub zurück nach england
weiter lieben freuen und zwar nach
london in die britische hauptstadt das
sind überhaupt nicht viele fahrräder
hier übrigens
wenn so viele also ich bei ihm überlegen
sich ja immer wie viele fahrräder
stellen wir hierhin sowie viele leute
brauchen die aber das sind ja 40 stück
oder irgendwie doch soll nicht um die
fahrräder gehen meine lieben freunde
sondern um das hier
ich könnte es nicht richtig erkennen und
da suche ich mir extra nen für euch
ja wir hatten schon eine piste kuhn
jetzt einen packenden hund noch mit
dabei gehe hier befinden wir uns in
valencia meine lieben freunde in spanien
sagen haben wir ein wunderschönes mehr
ein wunder wunder wunder wunder
wunderschönes mehr dass er zu glauben
war zu sein naja gut auf jeden fall
haben wir schöne häuser mir palmen die
zb klassische liegt natürlich der dhl
wagen wahrscheinlich hat er vorgestern
schon da sein müssen so wie ich dich
kenne auf jeden fall ein wunderschöner
ort mit wunderschönem wetter die frage
ist allerdings warum sie so schlecht
gelaunt ist
sie sitzt hier rum und weint
während ihre freunde oder familie dort
sind und diskutieren im meer
im viel zu blauen meer ich will auch
wieder ein urlaub aber gut machen wir
weiter mit mexiko meine lieben freunde
hier sind auf jeden fall einige
stromleitungen
sieht ja aus wie skilifte die ihr herr
fahrer gut das wetter spielte allerdings
nicht so ganz mit es ist sehr sehr sehr
sehr heiß in mexiko und ich bin auch
sehr heißen auf jeden fall haben wir
hier in mexiko einen super platzierten
baum
einfach mitten auf der straße der
einfach hier
ja
das war's hier befinden wir uns in
russland blieb meine lieben freunde die
nach huy
war das richtig
noch gebiet und zuckerberg und das war
naspa wir wenn du lust auf wunsch
besteht auf jeden fall sehen mich im
hintergrund schon ein extrem hohes
gebäude ich weiß nicht was das ist aber
dass eine kirche ist so gar keine ahnung
was allerdings habe ich auch rapunzel
rapunzel lass dein haar herunter dass
sie ihre haare wenn eine steckdose fast
seine podcast folge aufnehmen da ist
übrigens eine neue anlage montag
ja ich finde das opfer das sich ein t
shirt andere mit dem namen drauf naja
gut meine lieben freunde auf jeden fall
befinden wir uns hier in orlando und
hier ja gerade schon gesehen hat
befindet sich eine hand
im himmel
die hand gottes greift daraus wissen
dass da hinten
ist ja fast so lang wie man auf jeden
fall fand ich das hier wirklich ziemlich
krasse dass er einfach seine hand ist
ich weiß nicht ob die das extra gemacht
haben so bei google auf die sich extra
an einigen orten wirklich dachten border
baum erst einmal gucken wie viele leute
das finden aber was sind sonst eher
seiner hand vor die am 8
zu dem ort braucht
ich gar nichts sagen nein
was es ist
irgendwo wieder in amerika irgendwie in
british columbia oder so und es ist eine
ganz normale straße steht ein haus und
da sitzt er vor
wenn wir müssen nach hier geben er sitzt
er hat eine banane in der
in
wohnen ja ein bisschen weiter
die rhein gucken ist irgendwie da steht
auch karneval bei euch oder aber ob wir
nun allerdings auch schon zum vorletzten
lustigen google maps bonn.de nicht
ausgekannt habe es was ist das hier
ein haus wir können ein bisschen nach
links gehen und dann ziehen wir schon
beim
das sieht aus wie dieses ding aus der
kinderschokolade werbung wisst ihr wie
ich meine dass hier dieses milch herz
und das hat mich so ein bisschen daran
erinnert fand ich sehr lustig weil hier
zwei so kraftwerke kohle weiß ich genau
nebeneinander stehen das so hoch
zwischen es ist genauso aus wachs mal
daneben hier
na ja schon relativ ähnlich und für den
letzten google maps fail bzw
die lustige nächste komische sache die
ich dort gefunden habe dafür gehen wir
einfach nach orange in kalifornien
der ort heißt wirklich auf jeden fall
ist es sehr schön hier so typisch
kalifornien wieder mit den bäumen mit
den palmen ezb dann haben wir den hier
s
ist
dachte der sich so ja ich trage das ding
immer rumpf als segen wenn man google
street view auto kommen und dann halte
ich schnell raus
da was war da die mission mit an der
stelle mich dass heute ist allerdings
auch bei der lieben freunde werde ich
mal wieder google maps mit luca gefallen
hat das gerne einen daumen hoch oder
video da schreibt wir uns in die
kommentare wir weiterhin woche auf mehr
als google maps fehlt videos habt und
wenn ihr noch kein abonnent von meinem
kanal seit dann klickt klären hier oben
auf den zwei die drauf es ist kostenlos
und verpasst keine videos werden ich
weiß ja das ganze wieder von euch kein
abonnent sind schauen sich meine videos
anderen sind sich abonnenten da drauf
und hier ist ein anderer teil wo ich auf
google maps sachen reagieren
[Musik]